you're producing a show called celebrity
name game it's a game show it's a great
show it's on every single day of the
week it's really fun Craig Ferguson
hosts it it's not easy to play I am I've
been on it a few times and I don't have
a great memory and I did bring a clip
and I'm not sure be hard to play a game
show if you didn't probably have a good
memory or well first of all there's so
much pressure I mean even doing talk
shows is hard because you want to be on
and just but imagine like you're gonna
win people money or lose people money
and you feel bad and there's a clock and
pressure so I had to try to guess or
give clues on bands from the 80s
now I'm clearly in that age range and
this is in your wheelhouse you should
know this you show great at this let's
see how well you do oh wow I can't do it
that's right Steve Steven Tyler and i'm
steven perry them no no um big voice
long dark hair I'm Steven Tyler is it no
Perry steven perry and you go on a trip
you go on a basis you know avoid the
rappers they're there you know just wear
the hat the guys name it my CD no no
there there gert nut girls but they're
boys yeah what are they they're they're
monsters
this is terrible
okay you're listening when he dresses as
a woman Kaito
[Applause]
okay
[Applause]
that is unbelievable this is your show
[Laughter]
they didn't get anything yeah I was
terrible not wonderful right I like when
you just look at one and go now
wow it's so much pressure but it's
really a bunch of do you so you have a
bad memory you have the worst memory in
the world like no worse I forget when I
don't like somebody like I don't really
get when you you don't like someone you
forget that you don't like I walked into
this restaurant and I saw this guy from
across the way and I thought oh god
there's a feel of your face I was
waiting for a friend and I was like oh
hi and I went up and he looked at me I
was like hi I go on the tribe we hate
each other
I've never heard of that to lose your
memory of someone you hate I hate a lot
of people and I see them and I'm like I
hate that guy I don't know who his name
is I don't know what I don't know why
but I'll remember the hate hate I never
forget yeah that's good be hated by me
well yeah i'm you might despise me right
now and you're here you're probably
gonna realize in about 30 seconds I hate
Conan let's talk about Cougar tan is
premiering its sixth and final what's
together do we have you talked about
that last time
what's that we were at the White House
together years and years ago yeah
we got invited and you remember why we
were invited they were it was when I
guess I bet she doesn't yeah
quick Who am I let's do that one okay
I remember today was when when Bill
Clinton was president yeah and they had
an Irish they had a dinner sort of
honoring the I think Prime Minister
you're just pretending you know I do
it was honoring the prime minister of
Ireland and they needed quickly to get
some Irish celebrities to the White
House there you go and it was hilarious
I mean I got a call in there like you
got to get over here I had never been to
the White House before and I said really
and they're like we're just getting just
get over here we need people that look
higher they need anyone that looked like
a drunk leprechaun cuz we went there we
were in the line and we met yeah it was
very nice then you were sort of making
eyes at me and I was like not gonna
happen you probably forget that part
you